pierre moscovici ancien ministre de
l'économie est redevenu député
socialiste bon soir une soirée en
partant se dit-on à l'automne si tout va
bien pour la commission de bruxelles est
notre invité merci d'être avec nous nous
c'est à dire également perrine tarneaud
de public sénat et pierre glachant de la
fp donc pour cette émission qui
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la campagne
pour les élections européennes qui
s'ouvre officiellement ce lundi pierre
moscovici mans va d'abord évoquer
d'autres sujets d'actualité
je vous avais je crois à chanter la
marseillaise un bien oui usa mais nous
avons tous l'interpréter est ce que vous
imaginez ne pas l'entonner lors d'une
manifestation publique
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver ce prix
c'est fonction des événements non
monsieur c'est aussi un élan collectif à
certains moments je la chante plus
volontiers pendant les matchs du rugby
match de football au fanal quelque chose
une soliste s'en charge par exemple lors
d'une cérémonie officielle
je pense que je pense le vote très bien
que vous faites allusion qu'il faut
vraiment pas enfin un fromage parce que
christiane taubira est une femme qui est
une femme qui exerce des fonctions
d'état une femme qui croit dans son pays
une femme qui a du lyrisme
donc je trouve qu'on lui faire un
mauvais procès des jeunes m'ont dit
qu'il n'avait pas chanté non plus
arrêtons ça
moi j'adore chanter en général je dis
d'aggraver la situation
voilà moi je pense avoir l on peut tenir
la retirant c'est la même chose s'il
voulait que ce que j'exprime est oui
sans doute arrivé de ne pas chanter la
marseillaise un tel ou tel manifeste
étrangement est-ce que vous reconnaissez
au moins que l'expression karaoké
d'estrade utilisée par la ministre de la
justice et maladroite je pense que tout
a été dit je crois que derrière tout ça
on a un procès d'intention aucune
malveillance qui est excessif après
bombay par telle ou telle maladresse
c'est pas la question
target d'intention il ya les mots de la
ministre
quand on est ministre de la république
parlait de karaoké d'estrade pour
l'interprétation de l'hymne national
j'ai dit ce que j'avais dit d'accord ce
sujet bien à leur manuel valls comme
surtout pour moi c'est important c'est
qu'un ministre qu'il change ou ne chante
pas la marseillaise à telle ou telle
occasion et le service de la nation au
coeur qu'il soit un patrimoine qu'il
soit attaché à son pays et chanter c'est
bien alors manuel valls dénonce comme
vous mais sous les critiques à l'époque
on s'en souvient le rabot fiscal
donc il a annoncé une baisse des impôts
pour 650 mille ménages qui vont se
retrouver cette année et alors qu'on est
en pleine déclarations de revenus
contribuable donc pour la preuve pour
pas imposables pour la première fois six
cent cinquante mille ménages donc on a
une idée un petit peu de ce que ça va
représenter comme tout pour les planètes
je pense qu'on est encore aujourd'hui en
train d'élaborer la mesure est jugée dès
ce matin à l'assemblée nationale avec
des collègues et moi-même en deux comme
tuerie finances va attendre et comment
ce que ça veut dire mais vous disiez que
l'avait évoqué à l'époque ça me faisait
un peu sourire je pensais à cette phrase
du regretté de guerre fort on aime bien
au sénat qui disait c'est un grand tort
d'avoir raison trop tôt
à l'époque j'avais parlé de révolte
fiscale qu'est-ce qu'on n'avait pas dit
mais ce que je voulais dire par là c'est
quelque chose de simple c'est que la
gauche ne doit pas être assimilée à
l'impôt ce que je voulais dire c'est
qu'il y à un moment où la pression
fiscale devient telle qu'elle décourage
l'activité économique et qu'elles
découragent aussi les consommateurs de
consommer et donc elle est mauvaise pour
la croissance
et je pense en effet que alors que nous
avons dû c'est vrai ou monter les impôts
pourquoi parce que la droite avait
augmenté
ici de manière insupportable et c'était
la réponse à court terme que nous
devions apporter et bien en effet
maintenant il faut entrer dans une phase
d'abord où on a stabilisé les
prélèvements obligatoires depuis un site
où ceci diminue et salan voilà l'idéal
vous donne raison ça vaut pour les
entreprises
et ça c'est le sens du pacte de
responsabilité que qui veut déjà été
préparée à partir du discours du
président a répliqué le 14 janvier qui
permet d'avoir moins de charges pour les
entreprises qui permet d'avoir aussi des
impôts pour les entreprises qui sont
allégées pour que les entreprises
puissent investir et embaucher parce que
derrière ça l'enjeu c'est l'emploi et du
coup qu'il n'y ait aussi un geste sur
les ménages notamment sur les ménages
qui sont les moins favorisés me paraît
une bonne chose parce que c'est à la
fois la fiscalité des entreprises et la
fiscalité des ménages qui ne doit plus
augmenté qui doit diminuer de manière
juste voilà ça la ccga fort vais
résoudre des gars forts avaient raison
et voit aussi évoqué la sainteté turbo
qui turgot est derrière tout ça n'est
donc finalement c'est une filiation dont
je m'honore d'accord bon alors sur
l'orientation nouvelle dit certains ou
assumer enfin de l'exécutif on va parler
dans un instant pierre moscovici de la
politique économique que vous avez
évoquées mais néanmoins sur la baisse
des impôts annoncée pour les
contribuables les plus modestes
le président de l'ump jean françois copé
estime que c'est en fait une
échappatoire à la proche du scrutin
européen
on peut le voir aussi comme ça c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi
simplement il ya un projet loi de
finances rectificative qui est en train
d'être préparée il y à une attente de ce
côté-là y ait des engagements qui
avaient été pris lors du discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
savait jean françois copé c'est un homme
qui aime bien faire flèche de tout bois
de toute façon tout ce qui vient de la
gauche est mauvais même qu'on sait ce
qu'il préconise et en l'occurrence jean
françois copé a été aussi déjà le
responsable de l'ump à un moment où la
droite avait à la fois le laisser filer
les déficits accumulés l'endettement est
frappée fiscalement les français il n'y
a aucune leçon à recevoir de la part de
l'ump jean françois copé notamment en
matière fiscale
leur imagination fiscal a été débridée
sans limite et je pense honnêtement que
qu'il s'agisse de justice qu'il s'agisse
l'efficacité économique et pas de sens
souvent de l'ump s il ya des leçons
savoir de la gauche du ps qui critiquent
l'orientation économique que vous avez
défendu un instant pierre moscovici
on sait la guerre des gauchers relancer
et la grippe à venir des gauches et des
dialogues à mener il dire leur game né
voilà aider la commune et bien sûr parce
que il ya une majorité cette majorité
elle est diverse
le parti socialiste est un parti qui est
traversée en le seuil de sensibilité ce
qui compte c'est qu'on avance dans le
même sens il ya eu vote récent on a vu
comment il s'était déroulée maintenant
ce qu'il faut c'est bien répéter ma
peine ce qu'il faut c'est mettre en
oeuvre le programme de stabilité
il y à une majorité de gauche qui s'est
dégagé à ce moment là et ensuite il faut
se rassembler et je pense que ce qui
compte encore une fois pour le
rassemblement c'est le dialogue
oui mais pour ça il faudrait qu'il n'y a
pas de guerre d'accord il n'y a pas de
guerre mais plausible il devrait crier
un bon résultat socialiste aux élections
du 25 mai or tous les sondages annoncent
une défaite voire une catastrophe donc
est ce que ce n'est pas la crise
politique assure écouter d'abord ce sont
des élections qui se tiennent maintenant
dans quinze jours est ce qu'il faut
faire avant tout ce que je fais moi je
vais déjà fait je continue à le faire
par des débats par des émissions par m
on va le faire
non c'est surtout appelé les gens à
voter parce qu'il ya quand même un
paradoxe extraordinaire j'ai été député
européen deux fois et je l'étais de 94 à
et puis de 2004 à 2007 j'étais même à
l'époque vice-président du parlement
européen et j'ai vu à dix ans d'écart ce
parlement prendre des pouvoirs
considérables
aujourd'hui le parlement européen a plus
de pouvoir que nous allons entendre les
indigènes la deuxième partie c'est il a
plus de pouvoir que n'importe quel
parlement national il ya quand même un
paradoxe c'est qu'on confie à 760 hommes
et femmes des pouvoirs sur nos vies qui
sont considérables et on le ferait sans
que les citoyens se mobilisent donc
première chose votée nous mobiliser
ensuite c'est une campagne
aujourd'hui le résultat n'est connue par
personne et c'est une élection
européenne
donc je parle de ça aussi parce que je
pense qu'il ne faut surtout pas surtout
pas réduire ce résultat à une élection
franco-française je ne sais qu'elle va
fera quand même donné françois fillon
dire par exemple qu'il faut infliger une
seconde raclée à françois hollande après
celles des municipales
je pense que ce n'est pas digne d'un
ancien premier ministre je pense que
françois fillon ne comprend
ce qu'est ce scrutin européen on en
reparlera tout à l'heure ce caisson en
jeu et sa grandeur ce qui est en jeu là
et ce qui est en jeu c'est l'orientation
de la construction européenne qui ne se
sert pas et qu'on ne se servent pas de
ce scrutin pour exprimer uniquement
principalement a pas de preuves de
politique intérieure bien sûr la
politique intérieure n'est pas étrangère
et quand le peuple vote il ya toujours
des leçons en tirer mais ce qui compte
avant tout c'est qu'est ce qu'on attend
pour l'europe et je trouve que avoir ce
type d'attitude est mais c'est souvent
le cas chez françois fillon réducteur
politiciens parce qu'en fait ce qui est
en cause c'est qu'allons-nous faire
donnerait europe aussi la même chose en
fait aussi est aussi la nature du
soutien ou du rejet du couple exécutif
non je pense que c'est pas ça qui est
née alors je ne vois pas ça comme un un
vote de confiance ou de défiance pas du
tout je pense d'ailleurs que le résultat
sera celui d'une élection à la
proportionnelle qui est forcément est
propre à telle ou telle expression y
compris protestataires non il faut
d'abord se concentrer sur le résultat et
moi je vois deux ans je suis le meilleur
score possible pour le parti socialiste
pour le parti socialiste européen et
français
et puis la plus grande participation
possible
on a frôlé les 40% la dernière fois avec
une partie de ses seize années croire ce
serait là pour le coup je le dis ce
serait très mauvais pour la france parce
que nous nous affaiblit rions nous
aurions des députés européens qui
n'auraient pas légitimité forte alors
qu'ils auraient un pouvoir alors pas une
bonne chose dans ce contexte national
j'y reviens excusez moi on va parler de
reprise et un instant karma ce récit
passionnant porte bien sûr c'est bien
c'est bien est ce que le premier
ministre manuel valls et qui a donc
décidé de s'impliquer personnellement on
l'a vu sur tf1 dimanche soir il va
participer à des meetings à lille à lyon
et même à barcelone et ce qu'il prend un
risque inconsidéré
ou bien est ce qu il fait preuve de
courage il est dans son rôle
je pense que le rôle des hommes
politiques le rôle du premier ministre
le rôle des ministres le rôle d'homme
comme moi qui avons une voix européenne
à faire entendre c'est de se battre pour
ses idées d'accord mais il a encore de
bons sondages
encore une fois ce n'est pas ça qui est
en cause qui est en cause c'est une idée
c'est une conception c'est un destin
commun entre la france et l'europe et
six des hommes d'état venait dans une
élection comme celle ci à se dérober
bah il serait quand même comptable du
résultat de la même façon mais donc il
faut plutôt pesé sur les résultats
appeler les gens à voter et puis faire
en sorte que en effet le meilleur
résultat possible soit donné à la gauche
européenne on conseille aux 16 on
constate aujourd'hui que la personne la
personnalité de françois hollande est
contesté y compris en interne au sein du
parti socialiste pierre moscovici est ce
que l'idée de primaires au ps en 2017 ou
parer à une hypothèse crédible
moi j'ai été le directeur de la campagne
présidentielle de françois hollande j'ai
été son ministre pendant deux ans je
suis aujourd'hui député député de la
majorité je suis parfaitement solidaire
de l'action du président république et
au fond vous savez c'est à la fin que
tout cela se jugera françois hollande
avec ses gouvernements successifs mène
une politique de redressement nécessaire
au pays
trouvez le pays dans une situation
d'affaiblissement très important c'est
un homme qui suit son chemin non chaque
heure est donc validée enfin honnêtement
par les deux camps attendez la fin du
quinquennat pendant déjà parlé en 2014
2017 de un je ne sais quelle procédure
pour le choix d'un candidat franchement
les français n'attendent pas ça les
français attendent c'est le combat pour
l'emploi c'est pas pour unique but que
vous avez compris ce que voulait dire
françois hollande l'autre jour quand il
a dit alors à l'occasion du deuxième
anniversaire des élections
je n'ai rien à perdre je n'ai plus rien
à perdre il a surtout voulu dire c'était
un homme qui se consacre l intérêt
général qui n'était pas préoccupé par la
réélection est justement deux questions
d'actualité encore l'ump vous dites que
l'ump rejettent tout ce qui vient de la
gauche et le dénoncent la réforme du
millefeuille territorial telle qu'elle
est présentée en tous les cas même s'il
s'en défend les grands principes passé à
onze régions reviendrait à créer un état
fédéral du temps notamment à l'ump est
ce que ce serait une autre france comme
elle dit est ce qu'il faudrait passer
par un référendum dans ce cas là le nom
d'abord il faut être capable de
s'engager mais il me semble qu'il ya un
certain nombre de
d'hommes et de femmes de droite alain
juppé balladur
d'autres encore qui ont approuvé la
réforme du millefeuille territorial
pourquoi quand c'est nous qui le faisons
il serait t'il opposé dans le référendum
ne paraît pas quelque chose de
nécessaire en l'occurrence où toute
façon le référendum on le sait c'est aux
chefs d'état nous de décider tel moment
de l'utiliser ou pas et la question se
posera peut-être mais cet affrontement
de le faire notre constitution offre
plusieurs issus d'ailleurs la question
de savoir s'il ya besoin d'une vraie
forme grossier ou pas être une question
qui sera débattue le moment venu donc ça
c'est ma première remarque sociale
la deuxième l'est sur le fond c'est qu'à
l'évidence nous avons trop de régions en
france est trop petite région moi je
suis élu d'une région la franche comté
qui fait un million cent mille habitants
est prête à s'allier avec la boue regret
bien son identité sa visibilité est trop
faible et il en va de même par exemple
pour les agglomérations
je suis aussi en état fédéral pour vous
bien sûr que non de ce qui fait lanta
fédéral c'est le fait de savoir non pas
qu'elle le nombre de régions et s'il ya
des pouvoirs qui sont dévolues région
s'étant déroulé le fédéralisme c'est pas
ça le fédéralisme quand vous donnez aux
entités décentralisées des pouvoirs de
plus en plus fort et que vous en retirez
au pouvoir central qui devient à ce
moment là la fédération je trouve cette
remarque pardonnez moi de le dire d'une
stupidité qui illustre une
méconnaissance des règles politiques des
institutions politiques de la science
politique elle-même le fédéralisme ne
dépend pas du nombre des régions il
dépend du rapport entre l'état central
et les régionales est que les pouvoirs
dévolus aux uns et aux autres ça c'est
pour jean françois copé
on l'a bien noté allée pierre vachon de
la sp va nous rejoindre maintenant pour
évoquer donc l'enjeu du scrutin du 25
mai on parlera également de la position
de l'europe sur l'ukraine très important
une campagne difficile pour le parti
socialiste qui combat donc l'austérité à
bruxelles et on l'a vu qu'il applique à
paris camilla campus anneaux une europe
plus sociale moins austère c'est le
projet socialiste pour les élections
européennes
en même temps le gouvernement lance un
plan de rigueur un double jeu qui
exaspère même à gauche sur la question
européenne si vous me permettez
parce que c'est quand même un vrai sujet
je l' ai vécu en tant que ministre il
faut sortir du bas
il faut qu ça c'est dans la campagne du
ps qui dit non à l'austérité en europe
oui enfin européens français y'a un truc
qui marche pas le bal des faux culs
c'est ce double discours d'un côté le
gouvernement qui coupes dans le budget
de l'état et se vante de son courage
j'engage un plan de réduction de nos
déficits de 50 milliards ça n'a jamais
été fait nous voulons tenir nos
engagements
pas pour l'europe seulement pour nous
mêmes parce que nous ne pouvons pas
vivre avec des déficits publics et à
l'endettement qui pèserait sur les
générations qui viennent d'un autre côté
les socialistes vont jusqu'à remettre en
cause la règle des 3% devant les
militants des militants conquis le soir
du lancement de la campagne pour les
élections européennes
les critères de droit pur sang qui ont
été adoptées dans un temps ne peuvent
pas être aujourd'hui appliquée dans le
moment de la crise que nous vivons faire
passer ce message d'une autre europe
malgré le plan d'économies du
gouvernement guillaume balas y croire
ce matin ce candidat socialiste en ile
de france aux européennes
et c'est de convaincre quelques
parisiens il n'y a pas de fatalité
nous sommes dans un moment où il ya un
grand vent en effet néolibérale qui
souffle qu'il faut savoir résister qu on
peut faire des reproches au gouvernement
mais enfin on peut pas dire qu'un
consomme dans l'ultralibéralisme le
modèle social est quand même très
largement préservée après si on veut
changer les choses au niveau continental
que ça se passe difficile à croire pour
certains électeurs c'est plutôt
contradictoire parce qu'on n'y croit
plus enfin
tu as entre ce qu'ils disent qu'ils font
ils nous ont tellement promis des choses
que y'a rien à rien donc on n'y croit
plus il est bien là le plus gros défi
des candidats les français n'espère plus
rien de l'europe
seuls 35 % d'entre eux sont certains
d'aller voter
voilà donc les précisions sur les
sondages en ce qui concerne la
participation on en dise est un mot il
ya un instant pierre moscovici pierre de
la chambre la sp nous a rejoints devant
soir pierre alors vos questions sur
moscovici alors apparemment c'est le
grand écart entre le la volonté de
poursuivre l'austérité à bruxelles et ne
pas vouloir l'appliquer ne pas vouloir
ne pas pouvoir l'appliquer
comment les critiques sont très
importantes au sein du ps
on parle de bal des faux culs et sait
comment allez vous gérer cette
contradiction dans la campagne je veux
pas grande région d'abord première chose
qu'il faut dire c'est que la france
n'applique pas de politique d'austérité
il n'y a pas de politique d'austérité en
france il n'y a pas une politique
d'austérité en france et écouter les
déficits français sont aujourd'hui parmi
les plus élevés des grands pays de
l'union européenne à la fois ce qu'on
appelle un déficit nominaux les chiffres
absolus nous sommes autour de 4%
aujourd'hui et les chiffres 10,2 déficit
structurel c'est à dire ceux qui sont
indépendants la croissance et ce que
nous devons faire c'est réduire ses
déficits
non pas pour obéir à je ne sais quels
diktats car l'europe est pas une
contrainte simplement pour faire en
sorte que notre taux d'endettement cesse
d'exploser parce que l'endettement c'est
ce qui pèse sur les générations futures
et je rappelle que plus nous sommes
endettés - nous avons la confiance des
marchés par exemple plus chères sont les
taux d'intérêts plus cher il service de
la dette moi j'ai commencé ma vie
politique comme conseiller au cabinet
d'un ministre lionel jospin munication
nationale c'était en 88 c'est l'année où
le ministère l'éducation nationale et
devenu le premier budget nation
aujourd'hui c'est le service de la dette
qui est en train de devenir le gérant
entendu nouvel homme fort du ps les gens
c'est la contrainte des transferts
bureau chaque euro consacrée au
remboursement de la dette est un euro
inefficace qui ne sert ni au service
public ni à l'éducation ni à l'hôpital
ou
ni la santé ni à l'emploi ni à la
compétitivité ni à l'économie
bref ce qu'il faut absolument c'est se
désendetter et ma deuxième remarque
c'est par rapport aux 3%
j'ai été misés l'économie et des
finances jusqu'à il ya quelques semaines
et qu'est ce que j'ai fait l'an dernier
j'ai négocié à bruxelles un délai de
deux ans pour la france l'a rappelé
c'est en 2013 que nous devrions être en
dessous de 3%
nous nous sommes engagés à faire pour
2015 alors donc non il n'y a pas
d'austérité en france ça vraiment il
faut arrêter avec ce mythe
il n'y a pas un double discours où nous
serions austère chez nous et puis
militant pour les cavalcades à bruxelles
mais on risque des sanctions le sait
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la même vision
que nous a du rythme ce désendettement
j'ai pleuré j'ai une conception
peut-être ringarde de la politique mais
je considère que quand on a adopté des
traités quand on partage ses traités que
des partenaires qu'ils les appliquent
eh bien ce ne sont pas des diktats sont
des disciplines va nous avons senti que
nous avons consentis et des signes qui
sont utiles parce que si on est trop
endetté encore une fois on s'appauvrit
encore une fois on peut discuter sur le
rythme on peut vouloir compléter les
politiques sérieuses par des politiques
d'investissement quand on met en place
un pacte de responsabilité c'est en plus
pour la compétitivité
donc voilà il n'ya pas la contradiction
qui qui est semble-t-il présenté ici pas
l'austérité en france et en même temps
un sérieux qui est nécessaire et à
l'échelle française et à l'échelle
européenne
et que répondez vous par exemple mais ce
combat délice qui dit que nous les 3%
c'est peut-être période de crise actuel
ce n'est pas possible il parle de
l'après crise encore une fois nous
sommes sur un rythme qui est tout à fait
compatible avec ce que nous pouvons et
devons faire les décisions du
gouvernement qui avait été préparée
d'ailleurs par le gouvernement intérieur
dans le sens large
mais cette campagne pour les socialistes
avait un particulièrement difficile le
taux des eurosceptiques est très
important
comment allez vous gérer cette situation
qui à 15 jours des élections montrent
des sondages très préoccupant pour vous
première chose je ne crois pas l'euro
scepticisme des français
je ne pense pas ça du tout quand
j'examine l'opinion je la regarde de
près qu'est ce que je vois un les
français sont très attachés à l'europe
ils sont européens 2 les français
refusent à une immense majorité
la sortie de l'euro pourquoi parce qu'il
voit bien que ce serait synonyme
d'inflation de perte de pouvoir d'achat
de ce pécule à sion contre le pays et
elles sont raisonnables de ce point de
vue là mais mais le vrai problème c'est
qu'ils trouvent
et ils ont raison que l'europe n'est pas
assez performante efficaces et justes et
notamment qu'elle ne sert pas assez à
créer de la croissance et de l'emploi
le vrai débat il est là moi j'étais
chargé d'une mission parlementaire par
le premier ministre sur comment
justement on peut améliorer la
contribution des politiques européennes
à la croissance et l'emploi le vrai
sujet c'est une europe qui permette de
sortir du chômage et qui repartent de
l'avant parce qu'une chose c'est que
sont les eurosceptiques qui mène la
danse aujourd'hui vous affublez du
colbert européen
non moi je me sens pas du tout robert
parce que justement si vous voulez jeter
recteur il ya trois options dans cette
campagne européenne ya l'option des
populistes qui en l'occurrence ce sont
surtout les populistes d'extrême droite
qui disent sortait de l'euro cela
propose le recul en arrière la
régulation ya l'option des conservateurs
ou des libéraux se sont eux qui ont fait
en sorte que la crise se déroule comme
elle s'est déroulé ce sont eux qui ont
laissé faire à sardines de choses par
exemple indirecte de régulation
financière ce sont eux qui ont proposé
des politiques d'austérité dans
différents pays pour soi ce qui s'est
passé en grèce
et puis il ya une troisième voie en
quelque sorte c'est la politique des
sociaux-démocrates qui est basée sur la
régulation et sur le volontarisme et au
fond quels sont les trois enjeux de la
campagne
c'est un faire en sorte de contrôler le
parlement européen et pour ça il faut
voter c'est de choisir le président de
la commission européenne
parce que pour la première fois les
électeurs ont ce pouvoir et c'est à
travers ce choix du président leur part
les importations européennes troisième
réorienter l'europe vers la croissance
et l'emploi alors et donc moi je pense
que cette campagne dans ces 15 derniers
jours c'est la campagne officielle comme
aujourd'hui elle doit être totalement
totalement focalisé là dessus sur une
europe avec les sociaux démocrates
pour la croissance et pour l'emploi en
sortant des faux débats d'accord alors
précisément cette élection du 25 mai
elle sera t-elle vraiment déterminant
pour le choix du président de la
commission européenne
comme vous l'avez vu les réactions des
chefs d'état notamment de madame angela
merkel récemment était très attentiste
en disant qu'elle prendrait plusieurs
que les tractations
est ce que vous êtes bien sûr que ces
résultats des élections européennes vont
influer sur les chefs d'état on rappelle
qu'il ya le choix entre le socialiste
martin schulz et le conservateur mais
soyons clairs les gens connus car n'est
pas le plus conservateur des
conservateurs malheureusement il a
derrière lui beaucoup de conservateurs
donc ça donne en europe et alors
seulement si on ne raconte pas des
bobards leur l'importance dû choisir le
président de la commission je parlais
d'un homme que je connais pour lequel
j'ai plutôt de l'estimé personnelle mais
qui en même temps elle candidats aussi
de l'ump maker d'autres bons des partis
qui sont plus conservateurs que lui même
qui est une orientation plutôt
chrétienne sociale
alors je passe mon candidat c'est martin
schulz et je pense que sa personnalité
son énergie son projet sont nature à
bousculer les choses allaient faire
avancer non mais pour répondre à la
question directement et répondre à un
gala merkel est une règle qui a été
fixée de manière assez claire des
traités et si le résultat lui aussi est
clair si les nets
s'il ya une formation politique qui est
clairement en avance sur l'autre je
souhaite que ce soit les
sociaux-démocrates et socialistes
alors à ce moment là oui la logique veut
que ce soit le chef de cette formation
au plus tôt son candidat devant les
électeurs qui deviennent le président la
commission européenne et il sera très
compliqué ou qu'on sert pas de ne pas
prendre en compte c'est exactement ce
que dit le traité ce résultat là si en
revanche le résultat est ambiguë si et
oui c'est parce que je reviens je vais y
aller par un missile résultats dans une
fourchette de 5 à 10 sièges
à ce moment les choses deviennent plus
compliquées mais tout l'enjeu c'est ça
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il y ait un
résultat net un résultat populaire et
encore une fois les citoyens la peine
pour la première fois sur le choix du
présent la commission européenne dans
les précédentes commission c'était un
choix qui se faisait par de purs
tractations au
un du conseil européen à l époque ou
plus est l une des limites et cette fois
ci c'est au vote à la majorité qualifiée
donc la voix de chacun compte en effet
les citoyens le 25 mai auront le choix
entre monsieur juncker et monsieur
schulz entre une option plus
conservatrice et une option plus
volontariste notamment tourné par la
croissance et l'emploi
est ce votre âge très avancé pour ça tu
disais tout à l'heure ce n'est pas qu'un
vote en faveur des socialistes français
ou contre les socialistes français c'est
un vote pour les socialistes européens
et pour une orientation volontariste de
leurs pensions que ces élections sont
lisibles pour la plupart des citoyens
est ce que vous pensez par exemple qu'il
y avait dans certaines circonscriptions
il ya d un nombre de listes très
important 1,3020 équipe dans les
collèges c'est très compliqué j'en
conviens mais non c'est pas ça la
solution c'est encore une fois faire une
pédagogie européenne et mois ci mais
justement j'allais le dire
la pédagogie européenne et doit pas se
faire tous les cinq ans moment des
élections européennes
elle doit être constante constante savez
moi j'ai voué une grande partie de la
vie politique à l'europe
déjà il ya longtemps il ya 20 ans
j'étais député européen j'étais
militaire européenne j'ai été à nouveau
député européen comme mes finances j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps sur l'europe
c'est tous les jours tous les jours que
nous devons en parler tous les jours que
nous devons faire campagne en quelque
sorte et je parie en entend tous les
cinq ans et en suisse et oubliez juste
le fait qu'après le scrutin je pense
c'est vrai qu'une reprise sociale je
pense que la question c'est surtout ça
c'est de faire en sorte que fasse
entendre des idées européennes en france
et qu'on fasse entendre des idées
françaises en europe
j'utilise une formule parfois je dis il
faut faire aimer l'europe en france et
faire aimer la france en europe
ça c'est un travail qui exige des
européens et je pense en effet que les
hommes politiques les femmes politiques
français devrait davantage se consacrer
à cette tâche là parce que l français et
européens
c'est indissociable je le répète destin
commun il n'y a pas de france forte sans
une europe forte
il n'y a pas de report dans une france
qui sont chanceux lui car moscovici on
cherche la force de l'europe dans le
dossier de l'ukraine alors évidemment il
ya des sanctions supplémentaires qui ont
été prises
ce lundi à bruxelles ont fait rentrer de
nouveaux nouvelles personnes mc2
entreprises supplémentaires
pourquoi françois hollande ne va pas à
moscou comme nicolas sarkozy en se
souvient l'avait fait pour la géorgie
situation n'est absolument pas la même
c'était il y avait une situation de
conflit qui était tout à fait différente
lassé communauté internationale tout
entière qui est mobilisé et françois
hollande la diplomatie française sont à
leur place mais vous ne voulez qu'elle
est la force de l'europe je raisonnais
parham par une sorte d' a contrario
pardonnez moi dans l'europe aujourd'hui
il ya des pays comme la pologne comme
les pays baltes qui peuvent avoir sur
leur sol des minorités imaginez que dans
un pays comme la lettonie où il ya une
minorité russe je crois 40 % de
population décide tout à coup
d'organiser événements de l'extérieur un
référendum là que se passerait-il
c'est impossible et pourquoi est ce
impossible c'est impossible parce que
nous avons l'union européenne et
n'oublions jamais que l'union européenne
ça a été ça c'est la paix c'est la
démocratie c'est notre unité et à
contrario l'ukraine montrent ce cas un
déficit d'europe peut créer alors moi ce
que je souhaite évidemment c'est qu'il y
ait une diplomatie européenne qui soit
forte présent elle l'est c'est qu'il y
ait des voix disent pas s'entendre non
parce que si vous voulez dans cette
affaire là qu'il ya des principes qui
sont les principes assez simple c'est
d'abord un principe de désescalade d
escalade sur le plan sécuritaire c'est
un principe démocratique
cette année vers la fédéralisation nous
venons d escalade jeux pas justement de
la russie et de faire en sorte qu'on
arrête ces manifestations qu'ils
puissent être violente deuxièmement
c'est de faire en sorte que des
élections démocratiques puissent se
tenir en ukraine pour avoir un pouvoir
légitime et si cela n'est pas possible
alors la logique des sanctions de
s'imposer davantage en valeur et un
grand européen qui s'appelle valéry
giscard d'estaing qui a dit récemment
que les etats unis entretenaient le
désordre du crème c'est aussi votre
vision de l'action de barack obama
non non c'est pas mal merci pas vraiment
comment il peut dire ça mais sous le
respect que j'ai pour les gilets
j'ai aussi été membre de la convention
européenne était le président mais là
non mais pas d'accord merci car à
champéry terme de public sénat arrive
maintenant pour évoquer votre avenir en
europe mais également un peu votre
passage à bercy évidemment pierre
moscovici mais c'est le premier point le
premier sujet que développe
peu samia de sheer 3 avril 2014 après
deux ans à bercy pierre moscovici qui
quitte le gouvernement
c'est la seule grande figure du ps
proche du président à être remercié
il redevient simple député mais pas de
rancoeur ni d'amertume assure-t-il son
avenir politique est désormais à
bruxelles
françois hollande lui aurait promis le
poste de commissaire européen pour
succéder à l'ump michel barnier
une des craintes de françois hollande
à l'occasion des remaniements c'est que
les ministres qui recouvrent leur
liberté en profite pour s'exprimer et
pour raconter des choses qui sont pas
forcément très agréable pour le
président et le gouvernement qui
viennent de quitter
donc il ya une manière très simple de
les faire taire c'est de les occuper
leur promettre des postes
ancien député européen ministre des
affaires européennes de lionel jospin
pierre moscovici a le profil idéal pour
intégrer la commission a bercy c'est lui
qui a négocié un délai supplémentaire de
deux ans pour ramener le déficit
français en dessous des 3% du pib
et c'est précisément ce que lui
reprochent l'ump qui a appelé ses
députés européens a refusé sa
candidature qu'il est la qualification
certainement son image est désastreuse
il a l'image d'un ministre des finances
qui a été licencié par son président de
la république parce qu'il n'a pas
atteint les objectifs qui lui avaient
été fixés qui était de permettre à la
france de respecter ses engagements
européens et donc je ne pense pas que ce
soit une bonne solution pour la france
de présenter cette candidature
il lui faudra aussi faire face à la
concurrence dans son propre parti la
députée elisabeth guigou vise elle aussi
le poste de commissaire européen et elle
a reçu le soutien de laurent fabius
laurent fabius et pierre moscovici
s'entendent assez mal d'ailleurs laurent
fabius avait fait des critiques au sujet
de la manière dont pierre moscovici
tenait la machine de bercy et donc oui
il ya une concurrence à l'intérieur de
la famille socialiste
mais ce serait quand même extraordinaire
que laurent fabius parviennent à imposer
sa candidate contre le candidat qui est
celui du président de la république s'il
accède à bruxelles pierre moscovici
viserait un grand portefeuille
économique pas sûr cependant que la
france obtienne ce poste alors qu'elle
même a du mal à respecter ses
engagements budgétaires européens voient
la question belle manière de rebondir
pour vous je suis regardé ce petit
reportage vous soyez là c'est toujours
une bonne et moi parfois certain
journalisme à vous elle présente les
choses d'une manière un tantinet
anecdotique imaginez que ce serait
parfait vous vouliez répondre à la mi
journée
je veux aussi répondre alain lamassoure
mais si cette idée que ce serait pour en
quelque sorte me faire taire pour
provoquer un silence que françois
hollande je me ferais un devoir de
solidarité comme jamais aujourd'hui
c'est vrai mais c'est pas ça c'est que
c'est ignorer profondément ce que je
suis d'ailleurs je suis un homme loyal
et je vous le rappeler tout à l'heure
j'étais le directeur la campagne
présidentielle j'ai été mise pendant
deux ans pendant deux ans tous les
mardis à 17 heures je voyais le présent
la réplique toutes les décisions
économiques ont été prises par lui et
moi ensemble sous l'autorité bien sûr de
jean marc ayrault pour ce qui me
concerne et donc tout ça n'a pas de sens
si aujourd'hui je me suis intéressée par
ses fonctions c'est pour une raison très
simple c'est parce que c'est en quelque
sorte pauvres c'est parce que c'est pour
moi la poursuite d'une conviction intime
qui est que la france et l'europe ont un
destin commun et pour ne pas vous cacher
un secret c'est quelque chose dont nous
parlions déjà avec françois hollande
depuis plusieurs mois avant même ce
remaniement
moi je vois ça non pas comme un lot de
consolation mais comme un projet comme
quelque chose qui est pour moi une façon
de poursuivre une action publique une
action politique parce que un
commissaire est un homme politique de le
faire à un autre niveau en faisant
bénéficier et mon pays et l'europe d'une
expérience européenne que j'ai pu
acquérir et de ce point de vue là en
effet la petite phrase d'alain
lamassoure que j'aime bien
on se connaît bien et à la fois
inélégante et assez mesquine d'ailleurs
il devrait pas ignorer lui qui est
député européen que le jugement porte
d'abord sur la compétence et que quand
on devient commissaire européen
on reste certes attaché à son pays mais
on est avant tout un porteur de
l'intérêt général européen
quand vous dites que vous en parliez
avec françois hollande veut dire que
vous serez le candidat de la france aux
postes de commissaires qui revient aux
européens qui revient à la france
c'est à ça que je dis que c'est quelque
chose à quoi pourra pas je pensais à
quoi nous pensions le président qu'il
choisira camus il le fera en fonction
d'un certain nombre de critères
la seule chose c'est premièrement que en
effet ses fonctions m'intéresse que je
me prépare activement
deuxièmement que je crois en effet que
la petite expérience européenne que j'ai
je vais pas la répéter trois fois est
plutôt un atout troisièmement que je
connais en effet et les institutions
européennes et les politiques
européennes et les acteurs européens qui
je le crois nous respecte pensons par
exemple à mes collègues du de l'éco fine
moi je suis très heureux d'avoir
travaillé bien avec wolfgang schauble le
ministre allemand aussi bien qu'avec
george osborne le chancelier discipline
et ce n'est pas utile
et troisièmement il m'a été confié une
mission parlementaire pour six mois pour
travailler sur les politiques
européennes leur façon de contribuer et
et c'est incontestablement d'accord à
qui peut être réglé votre connaît bien
très bien même je dirais plus légitime
que dans la polémique qui peut ignorer
qui peut ignorer qu'il ya là une marque
de confiance plus présent l'accueil qui
lui promis cet endroit c'est tout après
aviez des revenus de l'interrogation par
rapport à ce que vous venez de dire
peut-être d'avoir répondu à michel qui
tient à ce que vous parlez
la salle était mineure je la prends des
internautes il remarque un jour matière
j'ai passé du tout je dis juge par
rapport à l'hiver les désirs vous avez
été chagriné par cette non mais je ne
saurais pas vous dire aujourd'hui que je
serai le prochain commissaire européen
ce serait outrecuidant disons que la
sculpture est ce que la concurrence est
ouverte au sein des partis associés
vous ne croyez pas je crois on parle
d'elisabeth guigou mais je respecte
profondément jeu toute la confiance
d'une l'accord du premier ministre
mais encore une fois c'est le moment
venu que les choses se décident rien n'y
a pas de campagne à faire sur un sujet
comme ça et j'ajoute une chose c'est que
avec laurent fabius mes relations sont
pas celles qui sont décrites c'est
d'ailleurs rendez vous avec lui le faire
mais je vais demander rendez-vous pour
lui parler de cette mission vient donc
vous parle effectivement de votre
mission confiée par matignon sur la
place de la france en europe on dit
quand même qu'ils aient une petite
magouille un peu électorale autour de
cette mission que vous a été confiée
parce que pour six mois on sait que du
coup votre circonscription est gelée
qu'il n'y aura pas d'élections
partielles dans le doubs et que c'est
votre suppléant qui vous remplace est ce
que c'est une manoeuvre de contournement
du suffrage universel à la fois dire que
je ne suis pas encore le commissaire
européen et déjà prévoir ce qui se
passera devant moi si je devenais non
j'ai pas m'en tenir à ça jeudi à leur
première chose que les missions
parlementaires
c'est bien que vous me posez la question
c'est pas une magouille c'est quelque
chose qui est prévu par la loi
électorale le code électoral l'élection
partielle mais non c'est il ya une règle
l'article l
au 144 du code électoral qui prévoit
cela et au sénat vous en avez des
parlementaires en mission
et si en effet au bout de six mois un
argumentaire demeurant mission à ce
moment là il est plus parlementaire il
sait son supplément qu'il remplace mais
moi vous savez j'ai rencontré la semaine
dernière et le premier ministre et le
président la république longuement et
ils attachent tous les deux de
l'importance à cette mission et leur
message il a été comme un endroit c'est
fait oeuvre utile c'est pas une mission
prétexte c'est une mission de fonds etc
la france est pas là dessus c'est sur la
contribution des politiques européennes
à la croissance et l'emploi
et d'ailleurs à telle enseigne que je
serai dès mercredi et jeudi à bruxelles
pendant deux jours pour toute une série
de rencontres parmi cette rencontre il y
en a une que j'ai demandé naturellement
c'est celle le commissaire français
actuel michel barnier
j'ai bien travaillé sur des sujets du
broker je n'ai pas l'intention de faire
de cette mission je ne sais quelles
salles d'attentes pour un post futur je
veux bosser des journaux c'est pour ce
soir
si je suis commissaire européen nous
verrons bien alors là ça je ne le suis
pas je l'appelle c'est le moment venu
que les choses se dessiner votre rapport
est attendu pour quand dans six mois
parce que pourquoi et vous êtes payé
pour cette mission par là du tout mais
je suis allemand je suis un
parlementaire je reste député je siège à
la commission des finances peut me
connaissent par coeur
évidemment c'est totalement bénévole gg
c'est vrai quelques rapporteur pour
travailler mais dire les choses c'est ça
bien goût franchement je suis ravi que
vous permettez m'exprimer là dessus
parce que il ya un climat
d'antiparlementarisme tellement malsain
parfois et d'euroscepticisme tellement
épais c'est simple cette mission il m'a
été demandé par ce sujet est important
et je veux me consacrer pleinement parce
que c'est utile utile à mon pays
utiles à l'europe bref des idées
françaises en europe des idées
européennes en france c'est ça qui moi
me motive et pendant six mois je vais
pas me tourner les pouces en attendant
tranquillement une nomination je vais
travailler pour ça que cette perspective
de la commission européenne est ce que
c'est ça qui explique que finalement
vous montrer très peu d'amertume à votre
sortie du gouvernement
c'est un tempérament d'abord moi j'ai
aujourd'hui 56 dans le temps passe ça
fait 20 ans que je suis parlementaire
j'ai été pendant ces 20 ans est un
ministre et comment voulez vous
quelqu'un qui était sept ans ministre
exprime une amertume quelconque face et
une chance extraordinaire combien des
personnalités politiques françaises ont
été cinq ans ministre
moi je suis reconnaissant à la
république je suis reconnaissant à ceux
qui m'ont nommé je suis reconnaissant à
travail et pour le reste en effet une
perspective qui nous permet de
poursuivre ce que j'aime être allé au
bout de votre chemin à bercy j'aurais pu
continuer voilà donc c'est pour ça vous
alliez faire de ma question vous avez
vous auriez de moitié mais je suis je
suis
une nature optimiste optimiste au sens
de l'optimisme de la volonté de l' envie
de faire nulle envie d'être utile
je suis pas du tout en train de
regretter ce qui s'est passé hier
je suis déjà projeté dans ce que j'ai à
faire demain et ça s'est produit tout de
suite je dis pas que j'ai été heureux
j'ai pas dis youpi ça y est g t ag fait
à bercy des choses importantes
nous sommes arrivés aux responsabilités
après dix ans de droite et j'ai été
celui qui a permis la mise en place de
la banque publique d'investissement de
la loi de séparation des actifs
bancaires
j'ai mené à bruxelles c'est vrai des
négociations difficiles et quand la
masse tourniquet pas de résultat ça n'a
pas de sens qui raconte sur la grèce moi
je pourrais raconter comment ses amis
l'ump avait laissé la grèce sur l'union
bancaire et c'est vrai que ce délai qui
a été obtenu de deux ans est un délai
utile parce qu'il nous permet justement
d'éviter l'austérité d'éviter et comme
la récession j'aurais pu continuer je
veux pas partir sur un bilan mitigé
parce qu'on vous a un petit peu reproché
un bilan mitigé jeunesse et là je pense
si vous voulez que c'est pas exactement
ça a battu maria empocher les jugements
qui ont été formulées maintenant je suis
très frappé de sa terre au fond bon
voilà il ya une nouvelle donne politique
dans cette nouvelle donne politique
moi j'ai plutôt souhaité me tourner vers
autre chose que j'en ai parlé avec le
président de la république
voilà j'ai aussi souhaité que les choses
se déroulent ainsi dans ce contexte les
jeunes et votre parti du gouvernement
qu'est ce que c'est ce parti qui est
très passionnant si vous auriez pu
continuer j'aurais pu je me demandais
non mais j'ai aussi
non c'est pas qu'on va demander si
j'aurais pu faire je m'en sentais
capable mais en même temps c'est vrai je
le répète que le perspective européenne
et une perspective à laquelle je pensais
depuis plusieurs mois
donc là je vais vous raconter cette
expérience un niveau pas un jour
peut-être mais encore une fois ce sera
un livre sans amertume
moi moi je suis pas là j'ai une chance
formidable pour fait ce que j'ai fait
j'ai une chance formidable pouvoir faire
ce que j'aime j'aime être député demain
si je suis commissaire européen
j'aimerais ça aussi hier j'aime être
mises et finance un tempérament heureux
juste pour finir ravi de la crèche et
dans le débat politique je peux me
permettre de dire des choses je me sens
libre voyez vous je me sens pas du tout
tenu par je ne sais quoi je me sens
solidaire et libre et responsable
peut-être pour finir sur les élections
du 25 mai sur les élections européennes
est ce que vous craignez un 21 avril à
l'envers c'est à dire avec une
qualification du front national qui
serait même en tête
je pense qu'on peut pas du tout pas du
tout jugé le résultat des élections
européennes que je ne connais pas encore
une fois tout est un cible avec le même
grille de lecture plus d'élections
nationales et notamment l'élection
présidentielle il n'y aura pas
malheureusement 85 % de participation
c'est une élection à la proportionnelle
avec un très grand nombre de listes donc
c'est favorable au défouloir et puis
avec la cnac devenant pleins pouvoirs
est ce que je souhaite moi encore une
fois je le redis c'est que ceux qui vont
voter
n'oublie pas l'enjeu et 7 ans j'ai
encore une fois c'est voter pour choisir
vos députés européens essaient
deuxièmement voter pour choisir le
président de la commission européenne et
c'est enfin voter pour choisir une
orientation progressistes pour l'europe
tout ça ça mérite mieux que de se
rapporter sans arrêt au débat franco
français
l'enjeu il est différent il ya des
grilles de lecture va être très franco
française de 25 mais aussi je souhaite
qu'elle le soit le moins possible et que
ce qu'on regarde avant tout ses
résultats en france parce qu'il compte
nous sommes un grand pays on désigne
beaucoup de députés européens
et puis c'est qu'avec l'agrégation du
front national sa veux dire que la
france perd aussi en importance au sein
du parlement européen s'il ya moins de
députés européens de gauche de droite de
l'ump les partis sauf si c'est pour ça
que je souhaite encore une fois qu'ils
maximum de députés socialistes ne fixe
pas de le score mais je crois que rien
n'est impossible et donc
mobilisons nous et puis deuxièmement je
souhaite qu'au niveau européen
l'agrégation développe permettent de
voir un président de la commission
européenne qui soit capable d'agir pour
la croissance et l'emploi
merci perrine bercy pierre moscovici et
à propos justement de la percée attendue
de l'extrême droite lors du scrutin du
25 mai mais pas seulement dans tous les
pays européens sachez que florent fini
pour la tête de liste fn pour le l'est
sera l'invité demain de preuve par trois
j'ai été candidat dans l'est et je
souhaite que les électeurs de l'est
restent dans une logique de progrès
merci à demain
ouah